احد الناجين من سرطان البروستاتا يتذكر
جيدا اليوم الذي شخص فيه مرضه
نظر الي الطبيب وقال لي البروستاتا لديك
مغطاه بالسرطان خرجت من الغرفه بكيت وشعرت
بالضياع والعجز
اكتشف سرطان بعد ان خضع لفحص دمين يسمى
بينت نتائج تحاليل دم ارتفاعا في نسبه
مستضد البروستاتي النوعي او بي اس اي اي
البروتين السكري الذي تنتجه خلايا غده
البروستاتا لدى الرجال بدا استخدام هذه
الطريقه في كثير من دول العالم منذ
ثمانينيات القرن الماضي لكن نتائجها ليست
موثوقه دائما تمت الان طريقه اكثر دقه
لتشخيص سرطان البروستاتا وهي التصوير
بالرنين للمغناطيسي
ما فعلناه هو دعوه الرجال الى التقدم
لزياره فحص سرطان البروستاتا وطلبنا منهم
اجراء فحص بالرنين المغناطيسي واختبار دم
للبروستاتا وما وجدناه هو ان التصوير
بالرنين كان اكثر فعاليه في الكشف عن
السرطانات التي تحتاج الى علاج من فحص
الدم بمفرده البروستاتا غده عضليه بحجم
حبه الجوز تحيط بجزء من البولي او الاحليل
في حاله اصابه الغده بالتضخم فانها قد
تعوق مرور البول او السائل المنوي عبر
مجرى البول يصاب واحد من كل ثمانيه رجال
بسرطان البروستاتا مع تقدم العمر وفي كثير
من الاحيان لا تظهر على الرجال اي علامات
او اعراض للمرض لسنوات لذا فان الفحص
المحسن هو الطريقه الوحيده لاكتشافه مبكرا
واذا كان المزيد من الرجال مثل ايرول
سيتعافون من المرض فان برنامج فحص سرطان
البروستاتا قد يحسن احتمالات ذلك لكن ثمت
حاجه الى اجراء مزيد من التجارب لتاكيد
قيمه فحوصات التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي
قبل انشاء برامج وطنيه لفحص سرطان
البروستاتا